Hi, it's Ira Glass. Today's This American Life was first broadcast back in 2002, which actually explains the premise of the show, which was to do an entire program based on the classifieds section of the newspaper. Now, of course, Craigslist has taken the place of a lot of this classified advertising, putting the entire newspaper business in peril. So in just seven years, this has turned into a look at what once was. Here's the show.
你好，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天这期《美国生活》节目最初是在2002年播出的，这其实也解释了节目的初衷：用报纸分类广告版面的内容制作一整期节目。当然，现在 Craigslist 网站已经取代了许多此类分类广告，导致整个报纸行业陷入危机。所以仅仅七年之后，这期节目就变成了一种对往昔的回顾。节目现在开始。
Marilyn Tanious has been working in the classifieds for 27 years at five different newspapers. And when she reads the ads, she sees things that you and I don't. The other day, she was sitting in her office at the Chicago Sun-Times with two of her colleagues and with me, flipping through the paper and telling stories. She talked about the gun ads that Timothy McVeigh used to take out in the Arizona Republic , back when she worked there, long before he blew up the Federal Building in Oklahoma. Or there was the time that Marilyn's own mother caught a thief when some stuff that had been stolen from one of their neighbors showed up in the For Sale ads. Then Marilyn turned the page and spotted this ad in the used car section.
玛丽莲·塔尼奥斯在五家不同的报社从事分类广告工作已经27年了。当她阅读这些广告时，她能看到你我看不见的东西。前几天，她和她的两位同事以及我坐在《芝加哥太阳时报》的办公室里，翻看着报纸，讲述着故事。她谈到了蒂莫西·麦克维在《亚利桑那共和报》上刊登的枪支广告，那还是在他炸毁俄克拉荷马州联邦大楼很久之前，她当时就在那里工作。还有一次，玛丽莲的母亲抓到了一名窃贼，因为他们邻居丢失的一些物品出现在了出售广告中。接着，玛丽莲翻了一页，在二手车版块看到了这条广告。
OK, here's an ad. Here's an ad that tells me something. OK, I'm going to read this ad to you. And I'm going to see, what do you think it tells you. OK. "Volvo, '92, a four-door sedan, automatic, mint condition in and out, 37K, Texas car, exclamation point, properly maintained and serviced, mechanically perfect, needs nothing. Must see to believe, respect, and appreciate, $5,850," and the phone number.
好的，这有一条广告。这条广告向我透露了一些信息。好的，我读给你听。然后我来看看，你认为它透露了什么。好的。“沃尔沃，92年款，四门轿车，自动挡，里里外外全新状态，3.7万英里，德州车，感叹号，妥善保养和维护，机械性能完美，无需任何修理。必须亲眼见证才能相信、尊重和欣赏，5850美元，”还有电话号码。
She looks at the three of us like, well, isn't it obvious? Then she points at the ad.
她看着我们三个人，眼神仿佛在说，难道这还不明显吗？然后她指着那条广告。
This line, "must see to believe, respect, and appreciate," this person doesn't want to sell this car. Someone has forced him to sell this car. It's either his wife, they had a baby, they have to get a minivan. I can tell he doesn't want to sell the car. He's upset. Respect it. You must see to respect?
这一句，“必须亲眼见证才能相信、尊重和欣赏”，这个人根本不想卖掉这辆车。是有人强迫他卖掉这辆车。要么是他妻子，他们有了孩子，不得不买一辆小型货车。我看得出来他不想卖掉这辆车。他很沮丧。尊重它。你必须亲眼见证才能尊重它吗？
Marilyn says that, when you read your newspaper, you've got the news part of up front, which gives you the public life of the city.
玛丽莲说，当你阅读报纸时，你会看到前面的新闻部分，它展示了城市的公共生活。
You have the sports. You have the entertainment. You have politics. But if you read the classifieds, it's really about individual, personal lives.
有体育、娱乐和政治版块。但如果你阅读分类广告，那其实关乎个人的私生活。
It's, "My children are grown up, do I really need the piano anymore?" It's, "I'm really broke. I have to sell my possessions to live." I think you really get a sense of people's personal lives.
内容是，“我的孩子们长大了，我真的还需要这架钢琴吗？”或者是，“我真的没钱了。我必须卖掉我的财产来生活。”我想你真的能从中感受到人们的个人生活。
With that in mind, a few weeks ago, we the staff of this radio program, took one Sunday edition of the Chicago Sun-Times , and that same week's edition of the Chicago Reader , which is this weekly paper that we wanted to use, because of the musicians classifieds and the personal ads that they run. And then we hit the streets, tracking down the ads. For instance, "New, never worn wedding dress, tulle beaded bodice, $750 or best offer." There are several wedding dresses and a bunch of wedding rings for sale in the Chicago Sun-Times.
带着这个想法，几周前，我们广播节目的制作组拿到了某周日版的《芝加哥太阳时报》，以及同一周的《芝加哥读者报》，这是一份周报，我们想用它，是因为它刊登的音乐家分类广告和个人征友广告。然后我们走上街头，追踪这些广告。例如，“全新未穿过的婚纱，薄纱串珠胸衣，750美元或最高出价。”《芝加哥太阳时报》上还有几件婚纱和一大堆待售的结婚戒指。
Well, the bottom line was he didn't want to marry me anymore. And I'll never get out of the dress what I put into it. I know I'm not going to get the money, but I would like it to find a good home.
嗯，归根结底就是他不想再和我结婚了。我永远也无法从这件礼服上收回我的投入。我知道我卖不到那么多钱，但我希望它能找到一个好归宿。
This is the woman who's selling this old-fashioned-looking dress. Before she broke off the engagement, like in any relationship gone bad, every little thing seemed symbolic.
这就是那位正在出售这件看起来款式老旧的婚纱的女士。在她解除婚约之前，就像任何一段糟糕的关系一样，每一件小事似乎都具有象征意义。
I collected this Classic Pooh. You know, Disney has this line of Winnie the Pooh stuff. And he bought me Mickey Mouse. And I'm looking at it, going, "Why did you buy this?" And he said, "Well, they didn't have Classic Pooh." I'm like, "But I don't collect Mickey Mouse." It was just, I don't know. You know me, but you don't care.
我收藏了这套经典维尼熊。你知道，迪士尼有这套维尼熊系列产品。他给我买了米老鼠。我看着它，心想，“你为什么要买这个？”他说，“嗯，他们没有经典维尼熊。”我说，“但我又不收集米老鼠。”就好像是，我不知道。你知道我，但你根本不在乎。
The same weekend, two hours after talking to her, we followed up on this ad, "Agoraphobics In Motion, A-I-M, meets weekly in Lakeview East. Call for more details." Agoraphobics, you may or may not know, are people who fear going out into public, being around other people. And come Saturday at noon, when the meeting takes place, it's at a restaurant. And guess what? Only one person has the courage to show up there. Apparently, this is par for the course.
同一个周末，在和她交谈两小时后，我们追踪了这则广告，“广场恐惧症患者在行动，A-I-M，每周在湖景东区聚会。致电了解更多详情。”你可能知道也可能不知道，广场恐惧症患者是指那些害怕进入公共场所、害怕与他人相处的人。周六中午聚会开始时，地点是一家餐厅。猜怎么着？只有一个人有勇气出现在那里。显然，这是常态。
The nature of your fear is that you don't want to join groups. But you have to join a group to get help for the problem. So it turns into a little bit of a vicious circle.
你这种恐惧的本质就是不想加入群体。但你必须加入一个群体才能获得解决问题的帮助。所以这变成了一个恶性循环。
Three hours later, a short drive away, there's this ad to answer. "House sale, featuring vintage furniture, linens, jewelry, books, postcards, and a steamer trunk. Same owner for over 80 years."
三小时后，在不远的地方，我们要去响应这条广告。“房屋清仓大甩卖，包括古董家具、亚麻制品、珠宝、书籍、明信片和一个蒸汽行李箱。同一位主人已使用超过80年。”
OK, we're trying to sell all the contents to help her pay for her nursing home.
好的，我们正在试图卖掉这里所有的东西，以帮助她支付养老院的费用。
Kathy Gemperle and Pam Ball are running this house sale for a woman named Frances, who's lived here since 1919, but is not present today to see strangers pick through everything that she has ever owned. She saved everything and organized her pen pal correspondences, carbon copies of letters, old birthday cards, all in plastic bags. As a librarian, she had a big collection of children's books. And she'd write in the front of her books where she bought them, under what circumstances. And not only that--
凯西·格姆佩尔和帕姆·鲍尔正在为一位名叫弗朗西斯的女士举办这场房屋清仓会，她自1919年以来一直住在这里，但今天没能到场看着陌生人翻找她一生中拥有的一切。她保存了所有东西，并整理了她的笔友通信、信件复印件、旧生日贺卡，全部用塑料袋装好。作为一名图书馆员，她收藏了大量的儿童读物。她会在书的前面写下她在哪里买的，在什么情况下买的。而且不仅如此——
She would write in a lot of these books, "Given to me by my dear brother." Well, he'd been dead for 30 years. So she would gift herself books and then write in the frontispiece that it was from them.
她会在很多书里写道，“我亲爱的兄弟送给我的。”嗯，他已经去世30年了。所以她会给自己买书作为礼物，然后在扉页写上这是他们送的。
This is a book, and Frances wrote in it, "From my brothers Victor and Laurie in heaven, because I've always wanted this book. To Frances on Thanksgiving." And then it's dated November 21, 1980.
这是一本书，弗朗西斯在上面写道，“来自我在天堂的兄弟维克多和劳里，因为我一直想要这本书。献给感恩节的弗朗西斯。”日期是1980年11月21日。
I mean, the inscriptions in these, "There was a vacant spot in my heart. Now it's filled with a great love, a love that's everlasting, my love for Frances." Her mother.
我是说，这些书里的题词，“我心中曾有一个空缺。现在它被一份伟大的爱填满了，一份永恒的爱，我对弗朗西斯的爱。”她母亲写的。
In this one day of classifieds, there are all the people trying to adopt babies, and all the formerly adopted babies who are now adults looking for their parents. There's a church selling off all its furniture, and the death notice placed by Local 17 of the Heat and Frost Insulators Union for one of its members. There are those weird ads that say "I am not responsible for the debts of so-and-so." And, this is a real ad, [? "Dan Earler, ?] if your belongings are not removed from 6123 South Archer Road, they will be discarded." And there are prayers. There are lots of prayers, every day in the newspaper.
在这一天的分类广告里，有所有试图领养婴儿的人，也有现在已成年、正在寻找亲生父母的曾经被领养的孩子。有教堂正在变卖所有家具，有热力和冷冻绝缘工会17分会为一名会员发布的讣告。还有那些奇怪的广告，写着“本人不对某某人的债务负责”。这是一条真实的广告，“丹·厄勒，如果你的财物不从南阿彻路6123号移除，它们将被丢弃。”还有祈祷。报纸里每天都有大量的祈祷。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. Today on our program, something we have never tried before, and we're not sure anybody has ever tried this before. We bring you an entire hour of stories found from one day's classifieds. We use the Chicago Sun-Times from Sunday, August 25, and the same week's edition of the Chicago Reader. The classifieds are a public space where intensely private thoughts are being expressed all the time, much like this radio program. Stay with us.
好的，来自WBEZ芝加哥电台，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。今天在我们的节目中，我们要尝试一些我们从未尝试过的事情，而且我们不确定是否有人尝试过。我们为您带来整整一小时从一天分类广告中发现的故事。我们使用了8月25日周日的《芝加哥太阳时报》以及同一周的《芝加哥读者报》。分类广告是一个公共空间，人们在这里时刻表达着极其私密的想法，这和这个广播节目很像。请继续收听。
OK, maybe this is a cheap move, but we're going to start our radio program today with the most poignant possible elements for any story. They are the lost and found column and a puppy. Here's the ad.
好吧，也许这招很廉价，但我们今天打算以任何故事中最扣人心弦的元素作为节目的开场。那就是失物招领栏和一只小狗。广告如下。
Stolen dog, black, toy poodle named Isis. Stolen 7/27/02 from the Armitage-Kinzie area. Call 312-719-3669.
失窃的小狗，黑色，名叫“伊希斯”的玩具贵宾犬。7月27日从阿米蒂奇-金齐地区被盗。致电312-719-3669。
The production manager for our show, Todd Bachmann, who normally is not on the air, but who helps us get our show on the air, wanted to get in on the action this week. And he was the one to check out this ad.
我们节目的制作经理托德·巴赫曼，他通常不在广播里发言，但负责帮助我们让节目顺利播出，这周他想参与进来。他就是负责调查这条广告的人。
When I saw this ad, the thing that hooked me was the word "stolen." The toy poodle wasn't lost, like most missing dogs are, but abducted. Leo, the author of this ad, was working in his garage while Isis played in the fenced yard just outside. When he came out, Isis was gone.
当我看到这条广告时，吸引我的是“失窃”这个词。这只玩具贵宾犬不是像大多数走失的狗那样迷路了，而是被绑架了。这条广告的作者里奥在车库里工作时，伊希斯就在围栏外面的院子里玩耍。当他出来时，伊希斯不见了。
His best guess about what happened is sort of incredible. Leo thinks Isis was taken by a puppy mill for breeding. Some neighborhood kids say they saw a woman come into Leo's yard and chase Isis around and around until she finally caught the toy poodle and ran off, kind of like a scene from 101 Dalmatians.
他关于发生了什么事的猜测听起来简直不可思议。里奥认为伊希斯被一个繁殖工厂抓走去配种了。附近的一些孩子说，他们看到一个女人走进里奥的院子，围着伊希斯追赶，直到最后抓住了这只玩具贵宾犬并跑掉，就像《101忠狗》里的场景一样。
So when I asked the kids, then everything hit the rotary oscillator. I don't know. Being a locksmith, there's a right and a wrong. And what's mine is mine, and what's yours is yours. And I like to keep the status quo. OK? That's why I'm in the profession, to help keep that status quo.
所以当我问孩子们的时候，所有事情都乱套了。我不知道。作为一个锁匠，事情有对错之分。我的就是我的，你的就是你的。我喜欢保持现状。好吧？这就是我从事这个职业的原因，帮助维持现状。
Leo misses Isis, and says his older dog, a 13-year-old Shih Tzu named Button, misses her, too. Leo had big plans for Isis.
里奥很想念伊希斯，并说他那条13岁的西施犬“巴顿”也很想她。里奥对伊希斯有宏大的计划。
What I wanted to do was mate her with Button for puppies. Yeah, Shih Tzu and poodle, a shidoodle. The best of both worlds, the little bit of playfulness, and the ability to do certain tricks and stuff, and then the calmness of the Shih Tzu.
我想做的是让她和巴顿配种生小狗。是的，西施犬和贵宾犬的混种，一种“西施贵宾”。结合了两者的优点，既有顽皮的天性，又有完成某些特技动作的能力，同时还有西施犬的沉稳。
Leo had adopted Isis only months prior to her theft, from a family who couldn't handle Isis's incontinence. According to Leo, this family just didn't get Isis at all.
里奥在伊希斯被盗的前几个月才领养了她，那是从一个无法处理伊希斯失禁问题的家庭领养的。据里奥说，那个家庭根本就不懂伊希斯。
They called her Amber. The dog is jet black, all black, gloss black, curly hair, except for the little red in the mustache. And they called her Amber. I have no clue why anybody would call a black dog Amber.
他们叫她“琥珀”。那只狗是纯黑色的，乌黑亮丽，卷毛，只有胡子上有一点点红色。而他们叫她“琥珀”。我完全不知道为什么有人会把一只黑狗叫“琥珀”。
And once her face was shaved, immediately I thought of a black granite statue of the Egyptian goddess, Isis. And when I said Isis, she just perked up her years. And her hair stood on end. You could just see that, her face cocked and everything, she liked that word. So that was her name.
而且当她的脸被剃干净后，我立刻想到了埃及女神“伊希斯”的黑花岗岩雕像。当我叫出“伊希斯”时，她立刻竖起了耳朵。她的毛发都竖了起来。你可以看到，她歪着头，看起来她很喜欢那个词。所以那就是她的名字。
I spent a few hours with Leo, running around in his minivan on his quest to rescue Isis. In addition to the classified ad Leo has in all the major daily and weekly papers in Chicago, he's flooded his local park with flyers, and has even taped an enlarged five foot by five foot version of it to his minivan. The flyers also offer a reward of $20.
我和里奥在一起待了几个小时，开着他的小型货车四处奔波，寻找伊希斯。除了在芝加哥各大日报和周报上刊登分类广告外，里奥还在他当地的公园里散发了传单，甚至把一张五英尺乘五英尺的放大版传单贴在他的货车上。传单还提供了20美元的奖励。
I'm a small guy. And I could offer the $100 reward or something. But I don't want the people to think that they can just steal a dog and get a lot of reward. I want them to realize also that the person that they stole the dog from doesn't have much, that that's not wealthy. Just because I got a poodle doesn't mean that I live in a Taj Mahal.
我是一个小人物。我本可以提供100美元之类的奖励。但我不想让那些人觉得他们可以随便偷狗并获得高额赏金。我也想让他们意识到，被他们偷走狗的那个人并没有多少钱，并不富裕。仅仅因为我有一只贵宾犬，并不意味着我住在泰姬陵里。
We head to the animal shelter, which brings in newly captured dogs from off the streets every seven days.
我们前往动物收容所，那里每七天就会带入新从街上捕获的狗。
[BARKING]
[狗叫声]
You be nice, or nobody's going to adopt you. Now, do you think anybody's going to want to adopt those teeth?
你乖一点，否则没人会领养你。那么，你认为会有人想要领养那一嘴的牙吗？
After scouring the rows of cages without success, we decide to head over to a Spanish-speaking paper called La Raza to place yet another ad.
在扫视了一排排笼子却一无所获后，我们决定去一家名为《La Raza》的西班牙语报纸再刊登一条广告。
Is this a help wanted ad?
这是招聘广告吗？
No, this is I had my dog stolen a while ago. I talked to you on the phone.
不，这是关于我前阵子丢了一只狗。我在电话里和你谈过。
For the ad in La Raza, Leo decides to take a more creative approach. He has the man at the desk read the ad back to him to make sure he got every word.
对于在《La Raza》上的广告，里奥决定采取一种更有创意的策略。他让柜台的工作人员把广告读给他听，以确保一个字都不差。
Stolen black toy poodle named, is it--
失窃的黑色玩具贵宾犬，名叫，是——
Isis.
伊希斯。
Isis. May have a contagious disease, lepto. Can cause liver or kidney failure in humans. Symptoms: dry  moth, shaky hands, light-headed, dizziness, [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
伊希斯。可能患有传染病，钩端螺旋体病。会导致人类肝脏或肾脏衰竭。症状：口干、手抖、头重脚轻、眩晕，[听不清]。
Desperate, after five dogless weeks, Leo has decided to put out an ad that says Isis suffers from a dog disease which is contagious to humans. He hopes that whoever took Isis will see the ad and come running back for some kind of antidote.
在失去爱犬五周后，绝望的里奥决定发布一条广告，说伊希斯患有一种对人类有传染性的狗病。他希望偷走伊希斯的人看到广告后，会跑回来寻求某种解药。
So that would be $25.50.
那么一共是25.50美元。
You guys ought to feel kind of ashamed of yourselves. Everybody else gave me at least one free ad.
你们这些家伙真应该感到羞愧。其他人都至少给了我一条免费广告。
Is that right?
是吗？
Yeah, because of the lost dog and stuff.
是的，因为是丢失的狗之类的。
OK, well, you know what, I'm going to do the same thing. I'll go ahead and run the ad at no extra charge.
好吧，你知道吗，我会做同样的事。我会免费帮你刊登这条广告，不收额外费用。
OK, cool.
太棒了。
Yeah, yeah. I feel for you.
是的，是的。我同情你的遭遇。
Despite all of Leo's ingenuity and effort, the ads just don't seem to be working. Even Leo says that if you don't find your dog after the first couple of hours, it's pretty unlikely you ever will. He keeps putting ads in the paper, though. He doesn't know what else to do.
尽管里奥付出了所有的聪明才智和努力，但广告似乎并不起作用。即使是里奥也说，如果你在最初的几个小时内没有找到你的狗，那么你以后找到的可能性就微乎其微了。但他还是坚持在报纸上刊登广告。他不知道还能做什么。
Well, Todd, thanks for that report. Let's try one last thing, since the ad doesn't seem to be finding Isis. We're joined in the studio here, Todd--
好了，托德，谢谢你的报道。让我们尝试最后一件事情，既然广告似乎没能找到伊希斯。托德，我们演播室里加入了——
Yes.
是的。
By you and by Leo.
由你和里奥组成。
That's me. And Button.
是我。还有巴顿。
And Button. Button is right here. Leo, over a million people are listening to us right now on the radio. So if I could just ask the people who are listening to just take a moment and turn the volume up on your radios. OK, Leo, call the dog.
还有巴顿。巴顿就在这里。里奥，现在有超过一百万人正在收音机里听我们说话。所以如果我能请收听节目的听众花点时间，把收音机的音量调大。好的，里奥，叫那只狗。
Here, Isis. Isis. C'mere, Isis.
过来，伊希斯。伊希斯。过来，伊希斯。
All right, if anybody hearing our voices right now notices a black poodle barking or wagging its tail in the vicinity-- what's the number to call?
好吧，如果现在听到我们声音的任何人注意到附近有一只黑色贵宾犬在叫或者摇尾巴——要拨打什么号码？
312-719-3669. You can turn your volume down now. It doesn't have to be so loud.
312-719-3669。你可以把音量调小了。不需要那么大声。
[MUSIC - "ISIS" BY BOB DYLAN]
[音乐 - 鲍勃·迪伦的《伊希斯》]
Actually, no need to call that number. Back in 2002, a couple weeks after the ad appeared in the paper, Leo found Isis. Some neighbors found her barking in their backyard.
实际上，没必要拨打那个号码。回到2002年，广告在报纸上刊登几周后，里奥找到了伊希斯。一些邻居发现她在后院叫唤。
Well, the Help Wanted section of the Sun-Times on August 25 was a thin four pages, which is a shame, because if you count people these days who have given up on finding a job, and people who are working part-time but want full-time work, the jobless rate in America right now is nearly 10%, according to the US Labor Department. That is really high. That's the highest since the 1980s.
嗯，《太阳时报》8月25日的招聘版面只有薄薄的四页，这很遗憾，因为如果你算上那些放弃找工作的人，以及那些从事兼职但想要全职工作的人，根据美国劳工部的统计，美国目前的失业率接近10%。这真的很高。这是自1980年代以来的最高水平。
And a lot of people who go to the Help Wanted section of the newspaper for jobs are people on the margins of society, people who need a job to reenter the world. Here are two of them.
而许多去报纸招聘版块找工作的人都是社会边缘人，需要一份工作来重新进入这个世界。这里有两位。
Yes. My name is [? William Telposci, ?] and I would like to set up an interview for your waiting staff. And I was-- oh, OK. Oh, OK. OK, thank you.
是的。我的名字是威廉·特尔波西，我想预约一下你们的服务员面试。而且我当时——哦，好的。哦，好的。好的，谢谢。
[PHONE DIALING]
[电话拨号声]
Good morning, Mr. Chadbury. How are you? It's going fine. My name is [? Helen Bowler, ?] and I saw that you have a listing for a waitress wanted. And I'm wondering, could I come by today or tomorrow and do an interview? Today would be better? What time?
早上好，查德伯里先生。你好吗？一切顺利。我的名字是海伦·鲍勒，我看到你们登了一则招募女服务员的广告。我想问一下，我今天或明天可以过来面试吗？今天比较好？什么时间？
My name is William, and I've been looking for a job for a year, faxing resumes, filling out applications. I usually try to fill out at least 10 a day. I'm looking at the Help Wanted ads. Over the past few days, I've been to McDonald's, Burger King, White Castle, Kmart, Walgreens, Chuck E. Cheese, all over the place.
我的名字是威廉，我找工作已经一年了，发传真、填申请表。我通常尽量每天至少填10份。我一直在看招聘广告。过去几天，我去了麦当劳、汉堡王、白城堡、凯马特、沃尔格林、查克奶酪店，到处都去了。
We are in Presidential Plaza, and we're on our away up to the 40th floor, to the Plaza Club in search of employment. And now we're on the 40th floor. This is a beautiful view. This job is a banquet service job for an upscale, hoity-toity club. Looks like where some snooty white folks come and drink after work.
我们现在在总统广场，正准备去40楼，去广场俱乐部寻找就业机会。现在我们到了40楼。这景色真美。这份工作是一家高端、高雅俱乐部的宴会服务员工作。看起来像是一些势利眼的白人下班后喝酒的地方。
Hi. How's it going?
嗨。最近怎么样？
Hi, how are you?
嗨，你好吗？
Good. Are you Helen?
挺好。你是海伦吗？
Yes, I am.
是的，我是。
OK. And what are the kind of hours that you're looking for?
好的。你想要找什么样的时间段？
I'm looking for either early mornings or late evenings.
我想要清晨或者深夜的时间。
Breakast and lunch shift.
早餐和午餐班次。
Wonderful shift.
很棒的班次。
Are you looking for something in fine dining, or are you looking for something in catering?
你是在找高级餐饮的工作，还是在找餐饮外送服务？
Fine dining would be more suitable.
高级餐饮会更适合我。
I always give myself a two-month span at looking for a job.
我找工作总是给自己两个月的时间限制。
Do have any experience in this field?
你在这个领域有任何经验吗？
Sure, I have.
当然，我有。
If that doesn't happen, at the end of my 60 days, then I take whatever is available, whatever I can find. I'm not particular anymore after the end of the 60-day run. It's been actually about 55 days already. So I'm pretty much getting fed up. If no one has called me by Monday morning of next week, then I'm going to go and get whatever I can get, even if it is a car wash job.
如果那没发生，在我60天期限结束时，我会接受任何现有的工作，任何我能找到的工作。在60天的期限结束后，我就不再挑剔了。实际上已经过去55天了。所以我已经受够了。如果下周一早上还没有人给我打电话，我就要去干我能干的任何工作，哪怕是洗车的工作。
Yeah, so at this time, I'm just taking the applications. And I am definitely going to give you a call by Friday. OK?
好的，那么现在我只是在收集申请表。我肯定会在周五给你打电话。好吗？
And thank you for taking out some day on your busy schedule.
谢谢你从忙碌的日程中抽出时间。
You're very welcome. My pleasure. My pleasure.
不客气。我的荣幸。我的荣幸。
Being a single parent, I guess I just haven't figured out how to do it all and work at the same time. So periodically, when my family needs me, I will not work. And when I need to quit, I quit. I don't like it to be that way, because it makes me look unstable. But I have to do what I have to do in order to prepare my family to go out there and do something, so their resumes never have to look like this one.
作为一个单亲家长，我想我还没搞清楚如何同时兼顾家庭和工作。所以每当家人需要我的时候，我就不工作了。当我想辞职时，我就辞职。我不喜欢这样，因为它让我看起来很不稳定。但我必须做我必须做的事情，以便让我的家庭为未来做好准备，这样他们的简历就永远不必像我这样了。
We're going in to the Cheesecake Factory. I was wonder if you were accepting applications for employment.
我们现在要去芝士蛋糕工厂。我想知道你们是否接受就业申请。
You can fill it out upstairs, and just give it to me after you're done.
你可以在楼上填好，写完后交给我。
OK. Thank you.
好的。谢谢。
You're welcome.
不客气。
My name's William. I was wondering if you were accepting applications for employment. I'm here about the job for the dishwasher, and--
我的名字是威廉。我想知道你们是否接受就业申请。我是来应聘洗碗工工作的，而且——
Fill out the application, and they'll call you back. OK?
填好申请表，他们会给你回电话的。好吗？
Well, we're just at the John Hancock center for a security job. But I found out that I don't qualify, because they want a blue card, meaning having a clean record, and a GED or high school diploma. And I don't have either one.
好吧，我们刚刚在约翰·汉考克中心面试了一份安保工作。但我发现我不符合要求，因为他们想要一张“蓝卡”，意味着要有干净的记录，并且要有GED或高中毕业文凭。我这两样都没有。
I'm 39, and I've been jobless for about five years. And I've been doing job search for the past year. I worked 15 years in a fast food restaurant. And I was a gas station attendant, groundskeeper for a cemetery, and for about two years, I was a short order cook.
我39岁了，失业大概五年了。过去一年我一直在找工作。我在快餐店工作了15年。我还当过加油站服务员、墓地管理员，还有大概两年时间，我是一名短单厨师。
I went in to work drunk one day. And that's when I found out that I had a real serious alcohol problem. And it took me from that time up until today to do something about the alcohol problem. It's been 13 months since I had a drink.
有一天我醉醺醺地去上班。就在那时我发现我有一个非常严重的酗酒问题。从那时起到今天，我花了很长时间去处理这个酗酒问题。我已经戒酒13个月了。
Cocaine and heroin, that was my drug of choice. Occasionally, I would take a drink. And in between using heroin and getting sober, I gave birth to two children.
可卡因和海洛因，这是我首选的毒品。偶尔我会喝一杯。在吸食海洛因和戒毒期间，我生了两个孩子。
I have this friend of mine. He prefers living out on the street, no money or nothing. That's what he chooses, for that to be his life. And I was going down that road, myself.
我有一个朋友。他更喜欢露宿街头，没钱也没什么东西。那是他选择的生活方式。我自己也曾走过那条路。
I had been what they call a kept woman. I always met men that wanted to take care of me. So a job wasn't important. I was young. And I wasn't thinking about tomorrow or I have no 401(k) plan, I have no old age into retirement money. So I wasn't thinking about all that stuff. Because when you're 18, you think you're going to live forever.
我曾是一个所谓的被包养的女人。我总是遇到想照顾我的男人。所以工作并不重要。我还年轻。我没有考虑明天，我没有401(k)计划，我没有养老金。所以我没考虑所有这些。因为当你18岁时，你以为你会永远活着。
I think turning 40 made a big difference in how I want to do things from now on. Then being a grandmother just really blew me out of the water. Whoa.
我觉得40岁对我以后想做事情的方式产生了很大的影响。然后成为祖母这件事真的让我大吃一惊。哇。
And I've gained more respect for authority figures. So it'll be easier working now, because I've accepted the fact that I do need a job. So that calls for me to humble myself now, where I wasn't early on in life.
我对自己更尊重权威人物了。所以现在工作会更容易些，因为我接受了我确实需要一份工作的事实。所以这要求我现在要放下身段，而我年轻时并没有这样做。
When I was growing up, my mother always told me that little things mean a lot. That's why I get myself up in the morning, get myself out of the house to fill out the applications, get the newspaper, fax out resumes. I wish I could answer what's taken me so long on getting a job.
我成长的过程中，母亲总是告诉我，小事意义重大。这就是为什么我每天早上起床，出门去填申请表，去买报纸，传真简历。我真希望我能回答为什么我找工作花了这么长时间。
William and Helen talked with Joe Richman of Radio Diaries. He put together their stories and thanks Strive, an employment service here in Chicago. Coming up, Jon Langford of the Mekons and the Waco Brothers tries to find out whether it is possible to create a workable band from the newspaper ads in just one day. That's from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International in a minute, when our program continues.
威廉和海伦与“广播日记”的乔·里奇曼进行了交谈。他整理了他们的故事，并感谢芝加哥的就业服务机构“Strive”。接下来，Mekons乐队和Waco Brothers乐队的乔恩·兰福德试图在一天之内通过报纸广告创建一个可行的乐队。节目将在片刻后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. If you're just tuning in, all this hour, we're bringing you stories that we got from the classified ads that appeared on just one day, August 25, in the Chicago Sun-Times, and in the Chicago Reader that same week. Often with the classifieds, you'll come across an ad where somebody is looking for something. And then, practically right alongside that ad, there is somebody else who is offering the very thing that that person is seeking. You've seen this?
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。如果你刚收听，整个这一小时里，我们一直在为你带来我们从8月25日这一天的《芝加哥太阳时报》和同一周的《芝加哥读者报》的分类广告中发现的故事。通常在分类广告里，你会遇到有人在寻找某样东西。然后，几乎就在那条广告旁边，有另一个人在提供那个人正在寻找的东西。你见过这个吗？
This seems to be especially true in the musicians classifieds. You'll see guitarist looking for drummer. And then right there, you'll see drummer looking for guitarist, right on the same page. It's kind of heartbreaking, really.
这在音乐家分类广告中似乎尤为真实。你会看到吉他手寻找鼓手。然后就在那里，你会看到鼓手寻找吉他手，就在同一页上。这真的很令人心碎。
So we got to thinking, what if somebody were to play matchmaker for all of those people and do what all of us think when we see those ads? Well, our producer Starlee Kine recruited Jon Langford of the Mekons to do just that, to go through the classifieds and create a band, a band culled entirely from the classifieds, to play together for exactly one day, long enough to gather together in a recording studio to record their one and only song. Starlee?
所以我们开始思考，如果有人为所有这些人当媒人，做我们所有人看到这些广告时想做的事呢？嗯，我们的制作人斯塔莉·凯恩招募了Mekons乐队的乔恩·兰福德来做这件事，去翻阅分类广告并组建一个乐队，一个完全从分类广告中挑选出来的乐队，让他们在一起演奏正好一天，时间长到足以聚在录音室里录制他们唯一的一首歌。斯塔莉？
Jon's never had to turn to the classifieds for bandmates. His band, the Three Johns, were such close friends that all three of them slept in the same bed while on tour. His country punk band, the Waco Brothers, was started at a club one night as a way to get free beer. And the Mekons, who have been together for 25 years, is mostly people he went to school with in Leeds.
乔恩从来不需要向分类广告寻求乐队成员。他的乐队“三乔恩”是如此亲密的朋友，以至于他们三个在巡演时都睡在同一张床上。他的乡村朋克乐队“Waco Brothers”是一晚在俱乐部开始的，作为获取免费啤酒的一种方式。而已经在一起25年的Mekons乐队，大多是他利兹学校的同学。
We have never really decided to form a band. They've just kind of appeared. It's like, you'd be sitting around in the pub and saying, "Well, we need to be in a band. Everybody else is in a band. Why don't we have one?" And it's been people pretty close to yourself, and with similar tastes.
我们从来没有真正决定组建一个乐队。他们只是出现了。就像是，你坐在酒吧里说，“嗯，我们需要组个乐队。每个人都在组乐队。我们为什么不组一个呢？”成员都是和你关系很亲近、口味相似的人。
We chose seven different musicians. The only thing they had in common was that no two of them would have played together under any other imaginable circumstance. Ad number one, "Indie rock bassist and drummer available with practice bass in suburbs. Influences include Shellac, Fugazi, Mogwai, and Blonde Redhead. Contact Ben." This is from their demo.
我们选择了七位不同的音乐家。他们唯一的共同点是，在任何其他可以想象的情况下，他们中没有任何两人会在一起演奏。广告第一条，“独立摇滚贝斯手和鼓手，有郊区练习室。受Shellac、Fugazi、Mogwai和Blonde Redhead影响。联系本。”这是他们的样带。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Ad number two, "Smooth, sultry, soulful female vocalist seeks jazz musicians for band."
广告第二条，“风格平滑、性感、深情的女性主唱，寻求爵士音乐家组建乐队。”
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Ad three, an acid funk percussionist named Steve. Ad four, an electric violinist named Nathan. He's working on a rock opera about a conspiracy theory. And at present, that's all he's at liberty to say about it. Ad five, "Experienced contemporary Christian worship leader musician, plays guitar. Available for Bible studies and large or small church situations."
广告第三条，一位名叫史蒂夫的酸性放克打击乐手。广告第四条，一位名叫内森的电子小提琴手。他正在创作一部关于阴谋论的摇滚歌剧。目前，关于这件事他只能透露这么多。广告第五条，“经验丰富的当代基督教敬拜领唱音乐家，弹吉他。可用于圣经学习和大型或小型教堂场合。”
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Ad number six wasn't like the other ads in the musician classifieds. It caught our eyes immediately.
广告第六条不像音乐家分类广告中的其他广告。它立刻吸引了我们的目光。
"Theremin effects and song player wants an audition to amaze you. I also play an incredible musical saw." We've got to go meet this guy.
“特雷门琴效果和歌曲播放者，想要一次试演来让你惊叹。我也演奏不可思议的音乐锯。”我们必须去见见这个家伙。
We're going. We're there.
我们要去了。我们到了。
I'll tell you what. There's not much amazes me anymore. That sounds terribly cynical, but I really am desperate to be amazed.
我告诉你。已经没有什么能让我感到惊讶了。这听起来非常愤世嫉俗，但我真的非常渴望被惊艳到。
The theremin, of course, is the only instrument in the world that you play without touching. You just wave your hand through the air above it, which alters the electromagnetic field. Somehow, this produces a sound like a flying saucer in an old episode of The Twilight Zone. We ring his doorbell.
特雷门琴，当然，是世界上唯一一种无需接触就能演奏的乐器。你只需在它上方的空气中挥动手，就会改变电磁场。不知何故，这产生了类似《阴阳魔界》旧剧集中飞碟的声音。我们按了他的门铃。
Hello.
你好。
Hello, Eric. It's Jon and Starlee.
你好，埃里克。我是乔恩和斯塔莉。
[? Eric Mueller, ?] the theremin player, turns out to be a retired factory worker who lives in one of those overstuffed apartments where every corner is fulled with tchotchkes and souvenirs from all over the world, in other words, pretty much exactly where you would imagine a theremin player living.
埃里克·穆勒，特雷门琴演奏者，原来是一位退休的工厂工人，住在一个塞满东西的公寓里，每个角落都堆满了来自世界各地的装饰品和纪念品，换句话说，这正是你想象中特雷门琴演奏者会住的地方。
How are you?
你好吗？
I'm OK, how are you?
我还好，你呢？
There are pictures of his wife and family everywhere. And it's the only apartment I've ever seen with a hand-painted mural that covers an entire wall and features both a waterfall and a volcano.
到处都是他妻子和家人的照片。这是我见过唯一一个有一整面墙手绘壁画的公寓，上面既有瀑布又有火山。
Wow, wow.
哇，哇。
We head into a little room in the back of the apartment, and he flips on a theremin, a thin, black box which looks no cooler than a clock radio.
我们走进公寓后面的一个小房间，他打开了一台特雷门琴，一个看起来并不比时钟收音机酷多少的薄薄黑盒子。
[THEREMIN PLAYING]
[特雷门琴演奏]
Would you like something classical, or would you like something contemporary? What would you like to have?
你想要听一些古典的，还是现代的？你想要什么？
How about "Danny Boy?"
来一首《丹尼男孩》怎么样？
Do you like that song?
你喜欢那首歌吗？
He pops a floppy disk into a keyboard for accompaniment, and positions himself in front of the theremin.
他把一张软盘塞进键盘进行伴奏，然后把自己定位在特雷门琴前。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "DANNY BOY" BY FREDERIC  WEATHERLY]
[音乐 - 弗雷德里克·威瑟利的《丹尼男孩》]
Eric's a 60-something-year-old man in a royal blue tank top and matching blue gym shorts. He's warm and grandfatherly. If he had reached down and pulled a "who's got your nose" on me, I would have been ready for it.
埃里克是一位60多岁的男人，穿着皇家蓝背心和配套的蓝色运动短裤。他温暖且具有祖父般的气质。如果他弯下腰对我做“抓鼻子”的动作，我也不会感到意外。
But when he sits down in front of his theremin, everything changes. This look comes over his face, a mixture of utter calm and complete confidence. His factory worker hands glide through the air. It's graceful, with a perfect economy of motion. I turn to Jon, and his mouth is open.
但当他坐在特雷门琴前时，一切都变了。他的脸上浮现出一种神情，一种极度平静与完全自信的混合。他那工厂工人的手在空中滑动。优雅，动作极其精准且经济。我转向乔恩，他的嘴张开了。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "DANNY BOY" BY FREDERIC WEATHERLY]
[音乐 - 弗雷德里克·威瑟利的《丹尼男孩》]
Well, we were going to ask you to amaze us, and you did. You just did.
嗯，我们本来要请你惊艳我们，你做到了。你真的做到了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I know. It's great.
我知道。这很棒。
You speak the truth.
你说的是实话。
I'm amazed. I told you, I'm amazed. I came here. I was going to say, I was going to ring your doorbell and go, Eric, amaze me. But then you wouldn't have let me in.
我被惊艳到了。我告诉过你，我被惊艳到了。我来这儿的时候，我本想说，我本来要按你的门铃说，埃里克，惊艳我吧。但那样你就不会让我进来了。
Before we arrived, we hadn't understood that when Eric says in his ad, let me grant you an audition to amaze you, he literally means exactly that. He brings people to his home, plays for them, amazes them as promised, and then never, ever joins anyone's band. It's just not what he's looking for.
在我们到达之前，我们没明白当埃里克在他的广告中说，让我为你提供一次试演来惊艳你时，他真的就是那个意思。他带人到家里，为他们演奏，按照承诺惊艳他们，然后就再也不加入任何人的乐队。这根本不是他在寻找的东西。
To be just a part of a big group, I don't know if I could be happy in that kind of a situation. I've always played the solo.
成为一个大乐队的一部分，我不知道我是否能在那种情况下感到快乐。我一直都演奏独奏。
Nonetheless, he agrees to sign up for our band. Later, back at Jon's house, the difficulty of what we're going to do starts to sink in. What song could unite an acid funk conga player, a sultry jazz singer, two indie rockers, a Christian guitarist, an electric violinist, and an amazing theremin player? What one composer could shoulder the burden?
尽管如此，他还是同意加入我们的乐队。后来，回到乔恩家里，我们要做的这件事的难度开始浮现出来。什么歌能统一一位酸性放克康加鼓手、一位性感爵士歌手、两位独立摇滚乐手、一位基督教吉他手、一位电子小提琴手和一位神奇的特雷门琴演奏者？哪一位作曲家能承担这个重任？
I don't know why I keep thinking Elton John. Maybe we should do an Elton John song, because everybody likes Elton John, don't they? Even I like Elton John sometimes. There's certain Elton John songs I love. I like "Rocket Man." I think that's a brilliant song.
我不知道为什么我一直想到埃尔顿·约翰。也许我们应该唱一首埃尔顿·约翰的歌，因为每个人都喜欢埃尔顿·约翰，对吧？甚至有时连我都喜欢埃尔顿·约翰。有些埃尔顿·约翰的歌我很喜欢。我喜欢《火箭人》。我认为那是首精彩的歌。
I think it's going to be a long, long time, since touchdown brings me down again to find, I'm not the man they think I am at home. Oh, no, no no. I'm a rocket man. Yeah, I mean, maybe "Rocket Man." We could have space effects in it. You know, the theremin. Why don't we do "Rocket Man"? Let's ask them if they'd do "Rocket Man."
我想那会是很久很久之后，因为触地让我再次落地发现，我不是他们认为我在家时那样的人。哦，不，不不。我是火箭人。是的，我的意思是，也许是《火箭人》。我们可以在里面加上太空特效。你知道，特雷门琴。我们为什么不做《火箭人》？让我们问问他们是否愿意做《火箭人》。
Hey, how you doing? Nice to meet you, man. That's Sam, playing guitar. That's Eric, with the theremin.
嘿，你好吗？很高兴见到你，伙计。那是萨姆，弹吉他的。那是埃里克，弹特雷门琴的。
The big day arrives. One by one, members of our one-day band show up at the studio, where Jon had recorded most of his own albums. Eric, the theremin player, brings his wife.
这一天终于到了。我们这支“一日乐队”的成员一个接一个地出现在录音室里，乔恩在那里录制了他自己的大部分专辑。埃里克，特雷门琴手，带了他的妻子。
And just like in any situation, the cliques immediately form. The rhythm section hits it off immediately. They make musician jokes, like changing the time signature from a 4/4 to a 6/8, that crack each other up.
就像在任何情况下一样，小圈子立刻形成了。节奏组立刻合拍了。他们开着音乐人的玩笑，比如把拍号从4/4拍变成6/8拍，这让他们笑个不停。
Every band has the guy who's a quiet lone wolf. And in this band, it's the electric violinist. He's off in the corner, practicing his violin and not talking to anyone. When I ask how he's doing, he tells me he can't hear himself through his headphones. And then he utters the last sentence you hope to hear when you're throwing a group of strangers together in a band.
每个乐队都有那个安静的独行侠。在这个乐队里，就是那位电子小提琴手。他躲在角落里，练习他的小提琴，不和任何人说话。当我问他情况如何时，他告诉我他在耳机里听不到自己的声音。然后他说出了当你把一群陌生人聚在一起组建乐队时最不希望听到的最后一句话。
I'm in anger management, actually.
其实我正在参加情绪管理。
He proceeds to scare me with stories of other recording sessions he'd been in.
他继续用他参加过的其他录音会议的故事来吓我。
Well, that was the same situation. I was in a studio like this, and I couldn't hear myself very well. So I took the violin by the neck, right here, and I basically just took it like, I don't know, an ax, and just went bam, and pieces went flying everywhere.
嗯，情况是一样的。我在一个这样的录音室里，但我听不太清自己的声音。所以我拿起小提琴的琴颈，就在这儿，基本上就像，我不知道，一把斧头，然后砰的一声，碎片到处飞。
And you've done this--
你做过这事——
Twice, actually.
其实两次了。
Twice?
两次？
So we're working on that.
所以我们正在处理这件事。
Musicians jam together a little. The singer, Karen, had told me on the phone that she hadn't played in public a lot, and she felt sort of shy about the whole thing. But there's something about the dynamic of being the singer in front of six musicians, that as soon as she gets up there, she seems to change, take charge.
音乐家们在一起即兴创作了一小会儿。歌手凯伦在电话里告诉我她没在公共场合演出过，她对整件事感到有点害羞。但作为在六位音乐家面前的主唱，这种动态有一些东西，让她一站上去，似乎就变了，开始掌控局面。
Meow.
喵。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And the band defers to her. Indie rockers shift to jazz.
乐队听从她的指挥。独立摇滚乐手转向了爵士乐。
One was the papa bear, one was the mama bear, one was a wee bear. One day, they were walkin' in the deep woods and talkin', and along she came--
一个是爸爸熊，一个是妈妈熊，一个是小熊。有一天，他们走在深林里谈话，她就过来了——
After maybe 10 minutes of this, they know each other well enough to play through "Rocket Man" for the first time.
在差不多10分钟之后，他们已经足够了解彼此，可以第一次完整演奏《火箭人》了。
I don't know, do you want to give a count?
我不知道，你想数拍子吗？
Do you want to go?
你要开始吗？
Yeah. 1, 2, 3, 4.
好的。1, 2, 3, 4。
She packed my bags last night, pre-flight, zero hour, 9:00 AM. And I'm going to be high as a kite by then. I miss the earth so much. I miss my wife.
她昨晚帮我打包了行李，飞行前，零点，早上9点。到时候我会飞得像风筝一样高。我非常想念地球。我想念我的妻子。
And suddenly, they're a band. The guitarist and singer come together immediately, matching each other note for note. The rhythm section joins in shortly after, one perfectly fused unit. The electric violinist jumps in next, followed by the theremin player, right on cue.
突然间，他们成了一个乐队。吉他手和歌手立刻合拍了，音符与音符完全匹配。节奏组随后很快加入，成为一个完美融合的整体。电子小提琴手紧接着加入，特雷门琴手紧随其后，完全按照节拍。
Jon's standing in the middle of the room, waiting to step in, but there's nothing for him to even do. And sure, this isn't a real band, and after today, they'll never play together again, and I know it's just a cover of "Rocket Man," but everyone in the room seemed to be feeling the same, all light and giddy and sentimental and corny. It came together so easily, like they'd been a band for years.
乔恩站在房间中间，等着加入，但甚至没他什么事了。当然，这不是一个真正的乐队，今天过后，他们将再也不会一起演奏，而且我知道这只是《火箭人》的翻唱，但房间里的每个人似乎都有同样的感觉，轻盈、愉悦、感伤且俗气。它结合得太容易了，就像他们已经在一起组队多年了一样。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "ROCKET MAN" BY THE ONE-DAY BAND]
[音乐 - 一日乐队的《火箭人》]
From that point on, everything falls into place. Jon takes the musicians in separately to play their parts. The rest of the band eats pizza and zones out, like a real recording session. When it's Eric's turn to go in, his wife straightens his shirt collar and gently touches his cheek. The angry violinist goes in with him, and the two of them playing together turns out to be the highlight of the whole session.
从那时起，一切都各就各位。乔恩把音乐家们分开录制他们的部分。乐队的其他成员吃着披萨，进入放空状态，就像真正的录音会议一样。轮到埃里克时，他的妻子整理了他的衣领，温柔地抚摸他的脸颊。愤怒的小提琴手和他一起进去，结果他们两个在一起演奏成了整个会议的亮点。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "ROCKET MAN" BY THE ONE-DAY BAND]
[音乐 - 一日乐队的《火箭人》]
Eric, that sounds great. I've got a request, though. Could you do the classic 1950s flying saucer effect, just about 20 seconds from the end?
埃里克，听起来很棒。不过我有个请求。你能在结束前20秒左右，做那个经典的1950年代飞碟效果吗？
Sure can.
当然可以。
And that could lead us out?
那能引领我们结束吗？
Sure.
当然。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "ROCKET MAN" BY THE ONE-DAY BAND]
[音乐 - 一日乐队的《火箭人》]
That was excellent. Fantastic. Do you do this around the house all the time?
那太棒了。极好。你平时在家一直这么做吗？
Afterwards, Jon and I go to his house and put on a CD for his wife. He can't get over how easy it was. His recording sessions never go this fast.
之后，乔恩和我去他家，给他妻子播放CD。他不敢相信这一切有多容易。他的录音会议从来没有这么快过。
I thought we wouldn't get through it for hours. And there might be some arguments, and people might think that some people weren't playing well enough. Maybe it means that people who put the-- actually taking out a classified ad implies some sort of skill or confidence, or desire to go in there prepared and ready to show off your stuff. Maybe it's like when you have bands with just old friends, then you can have people who can't really play that well.
我本以为我们要花几个小时才能录完。可能会有一些争论，有些人可能觉得别人弹得不够好。也许这意味着，真正刊登分类广告暗示着某种技能、自信或准备好进去炫耀的欲望。也许这就像当你和老朋友组乐队时，你可能会有那些真的弹得不够好的人。
[LAUGHTER] That might be the-- I don't know. And that was kind of refreshing, in a funny sort of way, to think I could go in a studio, just with a bunch of people who had never met each other before, and make something that was nothing to be ashamed of.
[笑声] 那可能是——我不知道。以一种有趣的方式，觉得我可以进录音室，和一群从未见过面的人在一起，做出一点也不丢人的作品，这感觉很提神。
Before we formed the band, Jon said there wasn't enough amazement in his life. But since then, he hasn't ceased to be amazed by all the lucky accidents and connections that came out of the classifieds.
在我们组建乐队之前，乔恩说他的生活里没有足够的惊奇。但从那以后，他从未停止过对从分类广告中产生的所有幸运巧合和联系感到惊奇。
Let me tell you about the taxi driver. I got the taxi driver today. I get in the taxi, he goes like, "OK, sir, which way do you want me to go, which way? You will be the commander-in-chief. And I am just your lackey. I'm just your flunky. I'll take you whichever way you want to go."
让我告诉你关于出租车司机的事。我今天坐了出租车。我上车时，他说，“好的，先生，你想走哪条路，哪条路？你是最高指挥官。而我只是你的跟班。我只是你的小弟。我会带你去你想去的任何方向。”
And I'm like, "OK. No, I don't want to be the commander-in-chief. You be the commander-in-chief." He's like, "May I ask you what you do, sir?" And I'm like, "I'm a musician." And he goes like, "I too like to play an instrument." And he whips out this huge flute.
我说，“好的。不，我不想当最高指挥官。你来当最高指挥官。”他说，“先生，我可以问问你是做什么的吗？”我说，“我是音乐家。”他接着说，“我也喜欢玩乐器。”然后他拿出了这把巨大的笛子。
He gets to the traffic lights. Yeah, under the seat. He gets to the traffic lights, and he starts pulling it out. "Tell me what you think of this." And he starts blowing.
他到了交通灯前。是的，在座位下面。他到了交通灯前，开始把它拿出来。“告诉我你觉得这个怎么样。”他开始吹奏。
He starts blowing this flute. And he's playing the flute. And I was like, "Oh my God. I'm just going to record a bunch of people who have never met each other. What am I going to do? Did he just join the band or something?"
他开始吹这支笛子。他在吹笛子。我心想，“天哪。我正要录制一群从未见过面的人。我要做什么？他刚才加入乐队了吗？”
So he stops at the next light, and he goes like, "Let me try in the higher register." I could have got him and Eric together, it would have been like, [MAKES EXPLOSION SOUND]. But then I said, "You know what I'm doing today? I'm going to a studio to record a load of musicians who have never met. And I could sneak you in, if you've got a couple of hours free and you want to come in."
所以他在下一个红绿灯处停下来，他说，“让我试试高音区。”我本可以让他和埃里克在一起，那看起来会像，[发出爆炸声]。但我说，“你知道我今天在做什么吗？我要去录音室录制一群从未见过面的音乐家。如果你有几个小时空闲想过来，我可以让你溜进来。”
But I said, "What are the chances that I'd be doing that, and somebody would start playing music to me on my taxi drive?" And he went like, "Are you at all familiar with the writings of Jung?" And he just pulls it off and says, "Look, synchronicity. That's what Jung talked about, synchronicity."
但我说，“我正要做这件事，而有人在我的出租车旅程中开始为我演奏音乐，这种概率有多大？”他说，“你熟悉荣格的著作吗？”然后他把东西拉出来说，“看，共时性。这就是荣格谈到的，共时性。”
And that's why he was my taxi ride to the studio. And he was perfectly-- it didn't seem odd to him at all. But he couldn't come in. He was very busy. But he gave me his phone number.
这就是他作为我去录音室的出租车司机的原因。而且对他来说，这一切看起来一点也不奇怪。但他没能进来。他很忙。但他给了我他的电话号码。
Well, the members of our one-day band, Eric Mueller, Nathan Swanson, Steve Ordauer, Kirk Markarian, Ben Mazza, Sam Cortesi, and singer Karen Cassidy. Jon Langford's latest solo release is called Gold Brick.
好吧，我们的一日乐队成员，埃里克·穆勒、内森·斯旺森、史蒂夫·奥道尔、柯克·马卡里安、本·马扎、萨姆·科尔泰西和歌手凯伦·卡西迪。乔恩·兰福德的最新个人专辑名为《金砖》。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "ROCKET MAN" BY THE ONE-DAY BAND]
[音乐 - 一日乐队的《火箭人》]
Visit our website, thisamericanlife.org, to download your own full copy of "Rocket Man," this version of "Rocket Man."
访问我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，下载您自己完整的《火箭人》副本，这个版本的《火箭人》。
It's hard not to feel voyeuristic when you read the personal ads there in the classifieds. People's hearts are right there on the page. Our producer, Jonathan Goldstein, decided to look into one enigmatic personal ad that we saw in the paper. It read--
当你阅读分类广告里的个人征友广告时，很难不感到一种窥淫癖。人们的心就写在那一页上。我们的制作人乔纳森·戈尔茨坦决定去探究我们在报纸上看到的一则神秘的个人广告。上面写着——
Joyce, I don't want another housekeeper. Ken.
乔伊斯，我不想再要一个管家了。肯。
Explain it.
解释一下。
Well, it's about a woman that I was going out with that I lost. She broke contact with me after going out for approximately three, four months. There isn't a great deal to tell. Enjoyed food, drink, music, the typical things that people do. She was just a tremendous influence in my life.
嗯，这是一个关于我和一个失去的女人交往的故事。我们在交往大约三、四个月后，她中断了与我的联系。没什么好说的。享受食物、饮品、音乐，人们做的典型事情。她对我的人生产生了巨大的影响。
So wait, about the house cleaning thing. Can you explain that? When you mention I don't want another housekeeper, what does that allude to?
等等，关于那个家务清洁的事情。你能解释一下吗？当你提到“我不想再要一个管家”时，那是指什么？
I wasn't really looking for someone else.
我并不是真的在寻找别人。
Did she call herself your housekeeper?
她自称是你的管家吗？
No. It was a joke between me and her. I don't know how well-taken it was.
不。那是我和她之间的一个玩笑。我不知道她接受得如何。
Explain her departure, though.
不过，解释一下她的离开吧。
It was brutally sudden. I found out what she did for a living, which is something that was part of her mystique as I was going out with her. Some allusions were made to being something like a secretary. And it was something that I probably should have tried to make more sense out of. And I found out that she was a sexual surrogate.
非常突然，很残酷。我发现了她的职业，这在她和我交往时是她神秘感的一部分。曾暗示她做类似秘书的工作。那是些我可能应该试着去弄清楚的事情。我发现她是一名性代理。
How do you mean? What is that? She performed sexually for another person?
你是什么意思？那是什么？她为另一个人提供性服务？
I assume that's what it is.
我假设就是那样。
So when you found out about this, was that when you ended things with Joyce?
所以当你发现这一点时，那是你和乔伊斯结束关系的时候吗？
Well, I didn't really end things. I gave her a call. And she said to me, this changes everything, doesn't it?
嗯，我并没有真正结束关系。我给她打了电话。她对我说，这改变了一切，不是吗？
And I was kind of caught off guard. I didn't know exactly what to say. So I just said that, like everything else, it changes everything, and it changes nothing. We're still who we are. But before I had a chance to say anything else, she said she didn't want me to call her again.
我有点措手不及。我不知道确切该说什么。所以我只是说，就像其他事情一样，它改变了一切，也什么都没改变。我们依然是我们。但在我有机会说其他话之前，她说她不希望我再给她打电话。
So the next time that you called her--
所以你下次给她打电话的时候——
That number was no longer functioning with her behind it.
那个号码已经不再通向她了。
So how hopeful were you when you put the ad in the paper that she would actually somehow see it?
所以当你把广告登在报纸上时，你有多大的希望她真的能看到它？
It's just a shot in the dark, just an absolute shot in the dark. There's a Chinese poem. I forget who the poet was. But it's real simple and short.
这只是盲目一击，绝对的盲目一击。有一首中国诗。我忘了诗人是谁。但它非常简单短小。
And let's see if I can quote it correctly. "I'm struck by the lightning of seeing you after you're gone." It's after you're with someone, sometimes their presence, as you remember it, can be as startling as lightning.
看看我能否引用正确。“我被你离去后看到你的闪电击中。”那是在你和某人在一起之后，有时他们的存在，正如你记忆中那样，可以像闪电一样令人震惊。
One of the things that the people at the Sun-Times said to me was that a lot of the classified section is really for people in transition, ditching an old life or starting a new life, whether they want to or not. And of course, in the For Sale section of the paper, people go to the classifieds to start a new life by buying the castoffs of somebody else's old life. And they end up with stuff that's heavy with history, but it's not their history.
《太阳时报》的人对我说的一件事是，分类广告的大部分内容确实是为处于转型期的人准备的，无论他们是否愿意，都要抛弃旧生活或开始新生活。当然，在报纸的待售版块，人们通过购买别人旧生活的遗弃物来开始新生活。他们最终得到了充满历史感但却不是他们自己历史的东西。
Jay Allison has been making his life over from scratch recently, buying other people's stuff from garage sales, from eBay, from the classifieds. As part of the project, he polled his own kids about what to buy. And as you'll hear, they were only intermittently helpful. And he made some phone calls to the Sun-Times classifieds ads.
杰伊·阿利森最近一直在从零开始重塑生活，从车库甩卖、eBay、分类广告中购买别人的东西。作为项目的一部分，他询问了自己的孩子该买什么。如你所听到的，他们只是断断续续地提供帮助。他还给《太阳时报》的分类广告打了几个电话。
What do you hate? Do you hate the house, or what it stands for?
你讨厌什么？你讨厌这个房子，还是它代表的东西？
Both.
都讨厌。
What's wrong with the house?
这房子有什么不好？
Dad. I don't know, look at it. It's tiny and small and falling apart. I wouldn't want to live here, even if we had to live here, like if you and Mom were still married. I still wouldn't want to live here.
爸爸。我不知道，看看它。它又小又破旧。我不想住在这里，即使我们不得不住在这里，比如你和妈妈还结婚的时候。我还是不想住在这里。
This house isn't falling apart. It's just--
这房子没有破旧。它只是——
It is, though. And the basements smells. And it probably has mice.
但它确实是。地下室有股味道。而且可能有老鼠。
After the separation, there was no choice but to get my own place. And I had to put things in it. I was going to be living by myself. And it had been about 25 years since I'd had to think much about what items I need or want in a house. So a few months ago, I got my little place, close to the old one, and began setting it up for myself, and for my three kids, whenever they're here.
离婚后，没得选择，只能自己找地方住。我得往里面添置东西。我要自己一个人住了。距离我需要考虑房子里需要或想要什么东西已经过去大约25年了。所以几个月前，我找了这个靠近旧居的小地方，开始为自己布置，也为我的三个孩子布置，每当他们来的时候。
First I got rid of things, things with too many small parts, and all the broken things I'd been meaning to fix. I brought the things that were emphatically mine, like my old motorcycle, and my old guitars. I brought the cockatiel and the python. Then I had to outfit the place. I kept a list. I got a cookbook, a grill, and bowls. I didn't know how much I liked bowls. They contain chaos.
首先我处理掉了东西，那些有太多小零件的东西，以及所有我一直想修但没修好的坏掉的东西。我带了一些明确属于我的东西，比如我的旧摩托车和旧吉他。我带了小鹦鹉和蟒蛇。然后我不得不布置这个地方。我列了一个清单。我买了一本食谱、一个烤架和碗。我不知道我有多喜欢碗。它们能容纳混乱。
And house plants, I'd never had them before. I wanted them now. And I asked the kids what they thought we needed in a home.
还有室内植物，以前我从来没养过。我现在想要它们。我问孩子们他们认为家里需要什么。
Do you think this house is homey?
你觉得这个房子有家的感觉吗？
Yeah, it's cozy.
是的，很温馨。
Yeah?
是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Does it have everything you need?
它有你需要的一切吗？
Not everything. You can never have everything you need.
没有一切。你永远无法拥有一切你需要的东西。
We got stuff to cook with, so we can eat. It's got clothes.
我们有做饭的东西，所以可以吃。有衣服。
Clothes, yeah, clothes are required. Food is good. A bed, everyone needs a bed. TV isn't required. I admit that I do watch TV, but I read, too.
衣服，是的，衣服是必须的。食物很好。床，每个人都需要一张床。电视不是必须的。我承认我确实看电视，但我也读书。
I like to go outside. I love going outside. I like to climb trees. I like jumping around. I like squirt guns.
我喜欢去外面。我喜欢去外面。我喜欢爬树。我喜欢蹦蹦跳跳。我喜欢水枪。
What else we need to get for this house to make it any homier, Lil?
我们还需要为这个房子买什么让它更温馨一点，莉尔？
I think it's pretty good, Dad. I like it the way it is.
我觉得这已经很好了，爸爸。我就喜欢它现在的样子。
You don't think I need to get anything else?
你不想让我再买点什么吗？
A dog? Oh, I want a dog.
一只狗？哦，我想要一只狗。
A German shepherd would be good, because they're good with kids and easy to train.
德国牧羊犬应该不错，因为它们对孩子很好，而且容易训练。
If I were to call up people who had dogs for sale, what should I ask them?
如果我要给卖狗的人打电话，我应该问他们什么？
What the dog's record of biting people is.
狗咬人的记录是什么。
Hello?
喂？
Hi, there. I'm calling about the German shepherds in the paper.
你好。我打电话是关于报纸上德国牧羊犬的。
Oh, yes. I do have German shepherd puppies, but what I have left is one female. And that is all I have left.
哦，是的。我确实有德国牧羊犬幼犬，但我剩下的只有一只雌性。这就是我剩下的所有了。
All right. So here are my questions. The first dog my kids said they wanted was a German shepherd. Do you have a lot of experience raising German shepherds?
好的。那这是我的问题。我的孩子们说他们想要的第一个狗是德国牧羊犬。你有养德国牧羊犬的丰富经验吗？
Yeah, but not around kids, really.
嗯，但在孩子身边，其实没有。
No?
没有？
No, not around kids.
没有，不在孩子身边。
What do you think about them around kids?
你觉得它们在孩子身边怎么样？
Well, they should be good, because when I was small, I had one. He was always [INAUDIBLE]. But you know what happened the other day?
嗯，它们应该很好，因为我小的时候，我有一只。他总是[听不清]。但你知道前几天发生了什么吗？
No, what?
不，发生了什么？
Look, I'm normal, right? And then in August, three weeks ago, I got a makeover. And I changed my hair color. I put on perfume. I never put on perfume. And I changed everything, my clothes.
看，我很正常，对吧？然后在八月，三周前，我做了一次大改造。我改变了头发颜色。我擦了香水。我从不擦香水。我改变了一切，我的衣服。
And there's this one dog, one of the German shepherd's, and she's a real mean bitch. And I hadn't been there in two weeks until last week. And then I went in there to the yard. You know what she did to me?
有一只狗，其中一只德国牧羊犬，她是一只非常刻薄的母狗。我两周没去了，直到上周。然后我走进那个院子。你知道她对我做了什么吗？
No.
不。
She bit me.
她咬了我。
What do you mean you had a makeover? You mean you changed the way you look? Now I'm curious.
你说的做大改造是什么意思？你是说你改变了外貌？我现在很好奇。
Yeah, I felt a little bit depressed and everything. So I changed everything. I changed my clothes. I changed everything. And I started going to a gym and everything. And I lost 10 pounds in, I don't know, in a month. And I don't know, I must have looked totally different for her.
是的，我感到有点抑郁之类的。所以我改变了一切。我换了衣服。我改变了一切。我开始去健身房之类的。我在一个月内瘦了10磅。我不知道，我看起来一定对她来说完全变样了。
That's funny. One of the reasons I'm looking for a dog is my life has changed a lot, too. My marriage has broken up, and I'm living by myself. And the kids are there a lot, but I'm thinking about getting a dog to make it more homey.
真有趣。我找狗的原因之一是我的生活也发生了很大变化。我的婚姻破裂了，我自己住。孩子们经常在这儿，但我考虑养一只狗让它更温馨一点。
Ah, cool. Cool. Yeah, well, they would be great around them.
啊，酷。酷。嗯，它们在他们身边会很棒。
What was your German shepherd like when you were a little kid?
你小的时候德国牧羊犬是什么样的？
Oh, she was super-nice. She was nice. She slept in my room. And she slept on my bed also. Yeah, because I was very lonely.
哦，她超级好。她很好。她睡在我的房间里。她也睡在我的床上。是的，因为我非常孤独。
I'm a very-- I don't talk to a lot of people. I'm more of a lonesome person. I don't know. I just slept with her, and I talked to her.
我是一个非常——我不和很多人交谈。我更是一个孤独的人。我不知道。我只是和她一起睡觉，我跟她说话。
I've never told anybody. But yeah, I have, when I was sleeping, I used to hug her and everything. And she was like my older sister.
我从来没告诉过任何人。但是的，我有，当我睡觉的时候，我曾经拥抱她之类的。她就像我的大姐姐。
Were your mom and dad together?
你的爸爸妈妈在一起吗？
They've always been together. But my dad, he's like this-- he's not mean. He's not mean. But he has this way of being. He never talks to us. He never hugs us or tells us things. So I was [UNINTELLIGIBLE] with a dog.
他们一直在一起。但我爸爸，他像这样——他不刻薄。他不刻薄。但他有那种为人处世的方式。他从不跟我们说话。他从不拥抱我们或告诉我们事情。所以我[听不清]和狗在一起。
Do you think you'll always have a dog?
你觉得你一直会有狗吗？
Yeah. I think I need a little friend. Yeah.
是的。我想我需要一个小朋友。是的。
What would you like a dog to be like?
你希望狗是什么样的？
Playful-ish, cuddly, soft, and stuff like that.
顽皮一点，可爱，柔软，之类的。
What kind of dog do you think I should call about?
你觉得我应该打听哪种狗？
One that stays small. I don't want a big one.
那种保持小巧的。我不想要大的。
Like what?
比如什么样的？
I don't know. No, one of the little ones that Britney Spears has and Mariah Carey has. They're this big, and they're so cute.
我不知道。不，布兰妮·斯皮尔斯和玛丽亚·凯莉拥有的那种小狗。它们这么大，它们太可爱了。
And that means you can carry them around with them like little babies, is that the idea?
意思是你可以像对待小婴儿一样随身携带它们，是这个意思吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I don't want to do that.
我不想那样。
Well, I don't want a big one that, like, ugh.
好吧，我不想要一只大的，那种，呃。
How about a beagle? What do you think of beagles?
米格鲁猎犬怎么样？你觉得米格鲁猎犬怎么样？
I love beagles!
我爱米格鲁猎犬！
I love them!
我爱它们！
Oh, I want a beagle.
哦，我想要一只米格鲁猎犬。
Hello?
喂？
Hi there. I'm calling about your beagle puppies.
你好。我打电话是关于你的米格鲁猎犬幼犬的。
Sure, what would you like to know?
当然，你想知道什么？
Are they pretty friendly?
它们很友好吗？
Oh, they're lovable.
哦，它们很可爱。
Yeah?
是吗？
Yeah. They're very friendly. They're very lovable. They demand love. And they demand passion from their owner.
是的。它们非常友好。它们非常可爱。它们需要爱。而且它们要求主人给予激情。
How do they demand it?
它们如何要求？
By following you around, wanting to hug on you, and wanting to jump up on you.
跟着你到处走，想要拥抱你，想要跳到你身上。
Do you think a dog can love you?
你认为狗能爱你吗？
Oh, yes. I've got a dog that's a poodle that's particularly mine. And I have a bad heart. And every time that I go in the hospital, she's lost. She'll sit and scratch at every door in the house. She'll go to the window and scratch. She'll sit and look for me every place in the house. If I'm in bed, she'll stay in bed with me until I get up to make sure that I'm getting up. If I lay back down in bed, she'll get back in bed.
哦，是的。我有一只贵宾犬，那是特别属于我的。我有严重的心脏病。每当我住院时，她就失魂落魄。她会坐在那里抓家里的每一扇门。她会走到窗边抓。她会坐在那儿看着家里的每一个地方寻找我。如果我在床上，她会和我待在床上直到我起床，以确保我真的起床了。如果我躺回床上，她也会回到床上。
So she just sticks with you.
所以她就一直跟着你。
Yeah. We love our dogs. Yeah, I need a heart.
是的。我们爱我们的狗。是的，我需要一颗心脏。
It's down to that.
归根结底就是这样。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Are you on a waiting list?
你在等候名单上吗？
Nope.
没有。
How's that going to work, then?
那怎么办？
You live with your life as you can. Maybe I'll come back as a dog.
你尽力去过你的生活。也许我会作为一只狗回来。
I think you should get one.
我觉得你应该养一只。
Why?
为什么？
Because, then when we're not here, you'll have someone to keep you company, and someone to take care of when we're not here.
因为，当我们不在的时候，你就会有人陪你，当我们不在的时候有人可以照顾。
You think I'm lonely?
你觉得我孤独吗？
I'm sure sometimes you get lonely. Everyone gets lonely sometimes.
我相信有时你会感到孤独。每个人有时都会感到孤独。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It's 4:00 AM. I'm in the bedroom. A dog explains those extraneous noises of an empty house. It breathes the same air with you. It needs an occasional conversation, a hand on the back, more so than a cockatiel or a python, anyway. It stays with you, even in the middle of the night, at 4:00 AM, when you've woken with a harsh taste in your mouth, and you're writing on a yellow legal pad in the dim light, and only the crickets and the wind outside, like now.
现在是凌晨4点。我在卧室里。一只狗能解释空房子里的那些杂音。它和你呼吸同样的空气。它需要偶尔的交谈，背上一只手，无论如何，比小鹦鹉或蟒蛇更需要。它会一直陪着你，即使在深夜，凌晨4点，当你嘴里带着苦味醒来，在微弱的灯光下在黄色便签纸上写东西时，外面只有蟋蟀和风的声音，就像现在这样。
The only pets I have now, and one of them is-- I have three kids. They're five, 10, and 15. And we have a snake that belongs to my son, who's 10. And we have a cockatiel. But a dog would be a big jump from a snake and a bird.
我现在唯一的宠物，其中一个是——我有三个孩子。他们分别是5岁、10岁和15岁。我们有一条属于我10岁儿子的蛇。还有一只小鹦鹉。但狗和蛇以及鸟比起来是一个巨大的飞跃。
Yeah. But you get a lot more affection from the dog than you would a bird and a snake.
是的。但你从狗那里得到的感情比从鸟和蛇那里得到的要多得多。
That's right. That's right. And I think sometimes my kids worry that I'm lonely in the house by myself. I think they'd like me to have a dog, because they would think that it would keep me company.
那是对的。那是对的。而且我想有时我的孩子们担心我一个人在房子里会很孤独。我觉得他们会希望我有一只狗，因为他们会认为它会陪着我。
Oh, I'm sure. They're always waiting for you. They're always happy to see you, no matter what happens.
哦，我相信。它们总是等着你。无论发生什么，它们总是很高兴见到你。
I mean, I lived with a man that beat me and held a gun on me. And I'd go to bed at night and wonder if that was the night was going to be my last night on earth. And I don't know. I just have such peace and happiness with the dogs.
我是说，我曾和一个打我并拿枪指着我的男人住在一起。晚上我会上床睡觉，想知道那晚会不会是我在世上的最后一个晚上。我不知道。我只是和狗在一起感到如此平静和幸福。
And to spend a day-- I said, if the Lord, if I knew the last day I had on earth, I would just want to be totally away from human beings and just let me brush my dogs, and clean my dogs. And I enjoy grooming those dogs. I can totally get lost. Just give me a dog, a brush, and a table, and forget you know me.
为了过一天——我说，如果上帝，如果我知道我在世上的最后一天，我只想彻底远离人类，只是让我给我的狗刷毛，清理我的狗。我很享受梳理那些狗。我可以彻底迷失。只要给我一只狗、一把刷子和一张桌子，忘了你认识我。
So we haven't decided on a dog yet. I'm dropping by the pound, just to see. Really, the fellowship of looking for a dog seems to help. Everybody in their lives has holes to fill. And they're even willing to talk about it, when you are. And that's good for now. The kids and I have plenty of time to get a dog.
所以我们还没决定好狗的事情。我打算去收容所看看。真的，寻找狗的同伴情谊似乎有所帮助。每个人生活里都有需要填补的洞。当有人愿意交流时，他们甚至愿意谈论这些。这对目前来说很好。我和孩子们有足够的时间去买狗。
By the way, here's the rest of the list of things I put in this house. Electric fans, a gas stove with visible flame for heat. New pictures of the kids in frames. Lots of old kerosene lanterns, good for parties, good for storms.
顺便说一句，这是我放进这个房子的其他物品清单。电风扇，有可见火焰加热的煤气灶。框里有孩子们的新照片。很多旧煤油灯，适合聚会，适合暴风雨。
One thing I went nuts buying was old kerosene lanterns. What do you think of that?
我疯狂购买的一样东西是旧煤油灯。你怎么看？
Yeah, no kidding. I think it's cheesy.
是的，没开玩笑。我觉得它很俗气。
Cheesy? Why?
俗气？为什么？
Because you have one hanging from every tree in the backyard.
因为你把它们挂在后院的每一棵树上。
Don't you think it's cozy?
你不觉得它很温馨吗？
No, I don't. Sometimes. You just have a special soft spot for them, because you had them when you were living in West Virginia.
不，我不觉得。有时。你只是对它们有特殊的偏爱，因为你住在西弗吉尼亚州时曾经有过它们。
I've started a collection of rocks taken from places we visit, and kitchen knives, old carbon steel ones, scooters, and helmets, a camera.
我开始收藏从我们去过的地方捡来的石头，还有厨房刀具，旧碳钢的那种，滑板车和头盔，相机。
Photograph us. Daddy. Here we are. Take a picture. We look cute.
给我们拍照。爸爸。我们在这儿。拍照。我们看起来很可爱。
Walkie talkies, colorful flannel sheets for the kids, and a gun. And the first thing, the first thing I got when I moved in, was rugs to soften everything, to mute the empty sound, rugs on the floor of my house when I moved in, so I could circle three times and lie down, like a dog.
对讲机，给孩子们买的彩色法兰绒床单，还有一把枪。第一件事，我搬进来时买的第一件事，是地毯，让一切变得柔和，为了消减空旷的声音，我搬进来时地板上的地毯，这样我就可以转三圈躺下，像一只狗。
Is there anything else I should get for this house to make it seem homier?
我还需要买什么让这个房子看起来更温馨吗？
Wall-to-wall carpeting.
满铺地毯。
Wall-to-wall carpeting in this old house?
在这个老房子里铺满地毯？
Yeah. It would be so much cozier in this house if you had wall-to-wall carpeting.
是的。如果你铺满地毯，这个房子会温馨得多。
But when I first moved in here, do you remember how many rugs I got?
但我刚搬进来时，你记得我买了几块地毯吗？
Yeah, but rug, schmug.
记得，但是，地毯什么的，算了吧。
Jay Allison, he never did get that dog for the kids. They are now 12, 17, and 21, though Jay recently remarried. And last month, he and his wife had an incredibly cute son. His radio story got support from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting, for the Open Studio Project. And you can hear more of Jay's work at transom.org.
杰伊·阿利森，他从来没给孩子们买那只狗。他们现在分别12岁、17岁和21岁了，虽然杰伊最近再婚了。上个月，他和他的妻子有了一个极其可爱的儿子。他的广播故事得到了公共广播公司的支持，用于开放工作室项目。你可以在 transom.org 听到更多杰伊的作品。
I'm in anger management, actually.
其实我正在参加情绪管理。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "ROCKET MAN" BY THE ONE-DAY BAND]
[音乐 - 一日乐队的《火箭人》]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。